Well.
Good morning.
I think we should get started and what
we'll be talking about this morning is
the germ theory of disease and a sense
it's taken us half a course to reach a
period when we begin to see
the development of what you
would probably recognize
as a scientific modern
medicine to appreciate the
enormity of what happened with
the germ theory of disease.
I think it's worth casting our eye
back to a point we had already reached,
let's say we compared the year 1789 with
1900 before 1789 and the developments
with the Paris School of medicine,
you'll remember that the conceptual
framework was dominated still by that of
Hippocrates Galen and humoral medicine
humor Elysium was in retreat.
As doctors,
we're absorbing ideas about the
circulatory system and the nervous system,
but the medical philosophy,
the vocabulary,
therapeutics and medical education.
We're still cast in the old framework
supplemented by other developments.
Astrology,
for example,
an epidemic diseases were thought to
be explained by the doctrine of Miasma.
That is the corruption or poisoning of
the air or malaria as it was called at
the time.
By 1900 I think it's clear
that more change had occurred.
Then all of the centuries
since Hippocrates combined
and a medical science who's
basic principles were recognizably
similar to our own today had emerged.
Furthermore, the speed of
change was gathering momentum.
As a 19th century progressed,
the closing decades of the century
witnessed a wholesale revolution with the
germ theory of disease
as its central feature.
This theory,
I'm going to argue was as important or
revolution as medicine in medicine as for
example,
Galileo's theory of the rotation of
the earth was to astronomy or perhaps
Darwin's theory of natural selection was
to biology or gravitation to physics.
So what I would like to begin with then
it's looking at what is the germ theory?
What words preconditions?
Who were the decisive figures?
What were the decisive events associated
with that famous trio of Louie,
Pastor Joseph,
Robert Caulk?
What were the implications?
Let's avoid the idea of a single
genius coming up with a great idea.
Let's question the vision behind
the idea of the Nobel prize.
I'm going to be arguing
that these discoveries that
culminate in the germ theory
had a long gestation period and we're a
collective process that required a long
train of preconditions.
Let's look at the preconditions first.
I'll argue that their conceptual,
technological and institutional.
Let's look at conceptual preconditions.
The germ theory of disease didn't arise
directly out of hospital medicine on the
Paris school,
but I think it's inconceivable without
the background of that development was
crucial to have a no zoology.
That is disease classification.
The idea of disease specificity that they
were specific entities and without the
idea of localism that is lesions and
also essential was the new development of
pathological anatomy,
a [inaudible] from the post
mortem and the Paris hospitals.
The idea of specificity was critical.
Any further progress to the idea of a
microbial disease depended on the view
that diseases didn't transform
from one into another.
Before the Paris school, it was
common to believe, for example,
that cholera to take one disease was
simply a heightened form of endemic summer
diarrhea.
It wasn't a specific disease and it grew
out of another preexisting condition.
Their germ theory dependent instead
on the conviction that they're stable,
unchanging disease entities that each
one is specific and has this specific
microbial cause,
but the followers of Louie
Pr Louis that is in Paris,
we'll carefully distinguishing one
disease from another and classifying them
didn't advance much towards the idea
of the causative pathogens behind them.
Now,
when we've talked about the Paris school,
I don't want to give you the idea that
all of the crucial figures in disease
specificity and no zoology,
we've French,
there were other crucial figures as well.
William Gerhard who distinguished
typhus from typhoid,
he had studied in Paris with Louie for
a couple of years and then returned to
his native Philadelphia
during an epidemic of typhus.
He dissected hundreds of cadavers and
discovered that there are lesions had no
resemblance whatsoever to typhoid.
There was William Bud who wrote an
important book called typhoid fever.
It's nature,
mood mode of spreading and prevention in
1873 and you referred to the unchanging
specific nature of the disease.
Let's listen to what he said.
He said this to propagate itself and no
other and not on a series of indefinite
progressions constitutes the very essence
of the relation on which the idea of
species is founded.
How much this implies in
the animal and plant world.
We all know it is strange that what it
implies in the case of diseases should be
so seldom recognized until now
or there was Pierre.
But I to know who believed that there
were more bid seeds that caused special
diseases just as every seed and
the natural history that is,
it gives rise to a determined species.
And he applied that idea to
diptheria just saw as um,
apples don't turn into wheat.
Apple seeds into wheat,
so to uh,
and Dominik diarrhea doesn't
transform itself into Asiatic Cholera.
There was an important transitional
figure to Claude bed nod of the power
school.
One of its stars who lived from 1813 to
1878 and an 1865 wrote an important book
called an introduction to the study of
experimental medicine where he presented
a critique of the Paris school.
He argued that diseases
were dynamic processes.
They weren't static in the way that the
Paris idea of nosy optinose ology seem
to suggest.
And he argued the thing hospitals
displayed the end stages of diseases,
not their beginnings.
And he argued the hospitals and clinics
had an excess of variables that wasn't
helpful for the further
development of medical science.
So we proposed an alternative that
was embodied in his title that is
experimental medicine.
And by that he meant laboratory medicine.
So he is one of the people who suggest
a new epistemology from medicine,
which isn't the hospital ward,
but the lab where you can
have the experimental testing
of single variables in
controlled settings.
Here was a new source of medical knowledge
done there.
If not,
then provides conceptual preconditions.
There were also institutional ones.
And here I'm thinking of the rise of
the laboratory of the university that is
full time professional scientists,
research institutions and Germany leading
the way rather than friends in this
development.
There were also technological foundations.
It's impossible to think of the rise
of the germ theory of disease without
microscopy.
Okay.
And so it was indebted to Anton von Living
Hope who lived from 1632 to 1723 and
develop the simple microscope.
And then in the 1820 [inaudible] and
thereafter there were major improvements.
The development of the compound
microscope and higher magnification,
the work of the Zeiss company
and the development of lenses.
There was also for a fourth precondition,
a lonely neglected pioneer,
and that was a Hungarian gynocologist
who lived in Vienna called Ignacio Filipe
Semmelweiss,
who's crucial idea would states from
the 1840s some advice noted that the
infection rate in childbirth was
much lower on obstetrical wards,
where women were delivered by midwives
rather than on wards where they were
delivered by physicians.
The reason had nothing to do with
their training or relative degree of
benevolence and malevolence.
The point was that the physicians
were just returning from postmortem
examinations from autopsies after which
at that time they didn't wash their
hands.
And so they were transmitting disease
to their patients from autopsies.
There were performing
in an adjacent building.
So Semmelweis suspecting,
you know,
though he didn't know the mechanism
that this was the case established.
Elaborate handwashing rituals using a
chlorinated lime solution a little bit.
The first hand sanitizer we might say,
and he noted that mortality
plummeted from 20% to 1%.
Unfortunately,
his own career was not a happy one.
He was mocked by his colleagues as a
charlatan and was actually demoted in his
own hospital.
Well then there's a fifth precondition
and that's the development of the basic
sciences and it's hard to
imagine as we'll see in a minute,
the rival of the germ theory
without chemistry in particular.
The specific issue that gave rise
to the germ theory of disease was
fermentation.
And pastor after all was originally
a chemist who in the 1860s became a
biologist and we should not that
he wasn't a physician. This is, um,
to introduce you to Louie pastor.
The immediate background to the germ
theory of disease involved the dominant
theory of the day,
which was called design
Monique theory of disease.
That is that it was a form of ferment.
A little bit like Patton
coffer had asserted caused
by some fermentation of dirt
or gang or sorry,
decaying organic material under the
right conditions of soil temperature and
moisture.
This fermentation would give off
a poison into the environment.
Also quite widespread was the idea of
spontaneous generation that diseases arose
somehow spontaneously in a particular
locality weren't brought in or imported
from the outside.
There was a famous experiments,
um, about this from the
eight s the 17th century.
It was radius maggot experiment.
The idea was that if you could have
rotting meat and you could cover it,
you wouldn't develop maggots,
but if you didn't cover it,
uh,
then you would find that it
was fill it full of maggots.
So the maggots didn't appear in
the rotting meat by some internal,
um,
mechanism of spontaneous generation
but were imported from outside.
And pastors we'll see in a minute,
takes up this very idea to the idea
that germs to like the maggots aren't
imported from outside.
The immediate issue for pastor
wasn't fact fermentation.
He began by studying the fermentation
of wine and beer and in particular their
spoilage.
At the time.
This was thought when he took up
his work to be a chemical process.
And remember that pastor was not a
physician but a chemist originally.
Well,
what he did was to discover that the
fermentation was caused instead by living
microorganisms,
bacteria that he identified
through the microscope.
Now this was a high profile investigation
in the 1860s for the simple reason,
there's a production of wine and beer
involved to a Francis major economic
activities,
no poster.
And this was part of his genius,
immediately made a far
reaching connection.
And his estimate,
the fermentation that he saw in wine
and beer now caused by bacteria was
analogous to putrefaction
and infection in wounds,
for example.
So we began to regard no disease as a
process involving microorganisms living
things.
This was work that posture conducted in
the late 1850s and 1860s and it marked
the first transformation in his career
from that of a chemist into a biologist
or we might say today a microbiologist.
He examined not only wine and beer,
he then turned his attention to milk
and it's souring and he wrote a book on
that.
And then a study on wine and a study
on beer now of great importance was the
fact that pastors discovery that
abnormal fermentation leads to spoilage.
Along with that one to
another discovery he made,
which was that this process
could be controlled by heat.
Okay.
Here was a major public health
discovery and the led to the process.
We now know as pasteurization,
so already in the 1860s pastor
was busily transforming biology.
Even if how do you stop?
Then his discoveries were already those
of a fully productive life's work,
but then in the 1860s came return
imposters interests from biology more
specifically to medicine and public
health and he began to study spontaneous
generation.
Now,
followers of pastor believed instead in
biogenesis with regard to call a road
that we already set examined.
What about which there was a debate?
The idea was that cholera
was imported from outside.
It didn't arise spontaneously.
It wasn't the transformation of some
other disease that already existed into
cholera.
Rather,
it was a specific disease that could
not arise as a heightened form of a
preexisting condition.
Posture also devised and well,
caulk didn't think this was so elegant,
but it certainly convinced pastor and
his followers of famous swan neck flask
experiment that is he sterilite a flask
with a swan's neck and found that if the
culture is boiled and the flask
prevents air from gaining access to it,
then there was no development inside of
organisms that we would call bacteria.
A culture of them could grow in the
flask only if germs were allowed to enter
it,
but if the neck of the flask is
broken and errors admitted, um,
you can see the neck
broken out the bottom,
then you get a luxurious development of
life and this has enormous implications
for diseases and wounds.
Pastor wrote simply,
there is no known circumstance in which
it can be confirmed that microscopic
beings came into the world without germs,
without parents similar to themselves.
Now postures success was partly based on
the fact that he was aware of the full
range of the scientific implications
of his work and he selected carefully
topics with high profile,
philosophical and biological interest.
He was an expert at cultivating the media.
That was one reason that spontaneous
generation had led to so much excitement,
but most decisive imposters work was
what he did in the 1870s as he turned to
diseases demonstrating the
full implications of his
ideas on fermentation in the
previous decade.
This new phase of discovery dispute
occurred despite the fact that in 1868 he
suffered a major cerebral hemorrhage
that left him paralyzed on his left side.
Now, what did pastor doing the
1870s that was so crucial? Well,
first of all,
I'll look at two major things that he did.
One is work with silk worms and
the other is work with chicken,
cholera and anthrax.
Uh,
the first thing was a major contribution
to the germ theory of disease
accomplished by the work with an
unexpected experimental animal.
That is the silkworm.
And again,
let's look at the fact
that fosters success.
His influence and his genius was in part
the fact that he took on really high
profile research topics.
That is to say disease of silk
worms were these diseases.
We're decimating one of France's leading
industries that is silk through a
meticulous and painstaking research
posture demonstrated that there were two
major diseases at work
affecting Frances silkworms.
He called them play bean and flushed it.
You need to remember them for our purposes
and asserted that both were specific
diseases caused by bacteria
and he immediately realized
that there were enormous
implications not only for silkworms
but for human beings as well.
He isolated then to germs affecting
silkworms and demonstrated that they were
responsible for specific
contagious diseases.
Pastor isolated a germ and convincingly
linked it with a specific disease and
the concept of specificity was at the
basis then of the whole idea of the germ
theory of disease.
Now you know,
pastor didn't invent
the idea of contagion.
You've seen it with Frauca steroidal,
you've seen it in John Snow who talked
about the possibility of animal qls and
there were other scientists, Kazimir de
Vein and France, the English physician,
John Sanderson,
who were also advancing a hypothesis that
they were finding microscope microbes
with their microscopes and hypothesizing
that they might be the agents of
disease,
but pastor was the first to provide a
demonstration and a specific case proving
that microbes were the causative agents
of specific diseases and he provided a
methodology for further experimentation
and discovery poster then turn from
silkworms two diseases,
the diseases of chicken,
cholera and anthrax.
Neither is responsible for extensive
human disease as both are causes of
diseases of animals.
But what was critical was the process
is work on anthrax help to establish a
model for investigating
infectious diseases and
establishing the claims for the
germ theory of and putting
that on solid foundation.
At the same time,
he made another major development.
His vision went beyond simply
demonstrating the germ theory,
although he did that.
In addition,
he developed a public health
practice that is vaccination,
which had been pioneered a hundred years
before and he helped now to found the
discipline of experimental immunology.
Now let's,
we've seen vaccination and
the work of Edward Jenner.
Let's define vaccination is the
introduction into the bonding
of either the whole or part of a disease
causing microorganism in order to teach
the immune system to attack that same
organism should it reappear in the body
through natural processes?
The mechanism is that the vaccine primes
the immune system to produce antibodies
or teachers and mean immune cells to
recognize and attack the organism that we
now know perhaps to be a virus,
a bacterium,
or a parasite of a different kind.
The problem of course,
was how to stimulate immunity
without causing disease.
Jenner benefited from the crossover
immunity from cow pox to smallpox.
Posture did something else.
He used the concept of attenuation
genders, the father of
immunology in a sense poster,
the founder of experimental immunology.
The idea he had was that live pathogens
could be introduced in the body,
but only after being treated in some way.
Heat for example,
or passage through a different host.
First was another in such a way then
that there are varying lengths is
diminished,
then they'll stimulate the immune
response without causing disease at all or
only a mild disease.
This discovery was made during his work
with the bacterium that causes chicken.
Cholera made sort of by chance,
serendipity player to roll.
He left a batch of bacteria untouched for
a week or so while he went on vacation
during the hot summer months on returning.
He found initially to his frustration
that the culture no longer produce the
disease when he attempted
to infect other chickens,
so he got a fresh batch of bacterium and
injected the same chickens with it as
well as a lot of new chickens and made
a surprising discovery that the original
chickens injected with the old vaccine
remained healthy and our terms,
they were immune.
While the new and previously
untreated chickens sickened and died.
He repeated the experiment several times
with the same results and concluded
that the summer heat had
changed or attenuated.
The culture of the bacterium.
Later techniques expanded the repertoire,
demonstrating that he could kill vaccines.
Have chicken cholera but
still induce immunity.
There were other vaccines that could
employ live but attenuated bacteria or
viruses.
Some used killed microorganisms,
some Muse subunit vaccines and the
processes of attenuation or not only heat,
but let's say for polio could be the
passage through formaldehyde and various,
there are other means attenuation though
what's critical to the development of
vaccine as a public health strategy.
But let's return to pastor having
discovered attenuation with chicken.
Cholera pastor applied the same principle
to the different disease of anthrax.
The passage and responsible
was the bacillus [inaudible]
that had recently been
isolated by Robert Call
and if you see the film,
the story of Louie Pastor,
you'll see what he did in
1881 with the bacterium.
In a famous experiment,
he vaccinated 24 sheep
within an attenuated that is
heated bacterium after which
he challenged the original 24 sheet
with live unattended weighted anthrax
injections as well as 24 control
sheep that had not been vaccinated.
The vaccinated sheep remained healthy,
the non-vaccinated all died.
Then came the 1880s and pastor turned
to another high profile disease and that
is rabies.
Having discovered attenuation
by heat with chicken,
cholera and anthrax pastor extended the
principle of attenuation by other means.
This involved further famous experiments.
Rabies,
as it turns out,
was not another bacterial disease,
but a disease caused by what
we now know to be a virus.
In this case,
he attenuated the virus by isolating it
from foxes and then passing it through
an unnatural host of a different species.
In this case,
the rabbit,
so passing the virus through
a series of rabbit bodies,
he succeeded in a variant that would no
longer caused the infection and foxes,
but which serve to protect against
the natural occurring rabies.
Rabies was not a high impact disease
in terms of numbers of people.
It affected,
but it was a disease of high drama
and one that was then and still is
universally fatal.
So it was ideal for
attracting media attention.
The great human trial occurred in July,
1885 with the famous case of the
nine year old boy, Joseph Meister,
who had been severely bitten by a rabid
dog and was thought to be certain to die
an agonizing death,
but taking advantage of the
incubation period for rabies posture,
vaccinated the boy with his
attenuated rabies virus.
Joseph meister survived and
became a celebrity patient.
The first person ever known to survive
after being severely writ bitten by a
rabid animal.
And my store remained loyal for
the rest of his life to pastor.
He returned as an adult to parish to
work as a gatekeeper at the posture
institute. We're posture and
self was buried in the crypt.
The Apocryphal story,
I won't assert it's true.
The story is that he was killed in
1940 as an elderly men when he tried to
prevent occupying German troops
from desecrating postures grave,
the grave of the natural icon
national icon of an enemy power.
We're slightly less poignant,
but better documented narrative is that
he committed suicide in despair at the
German occupation. Well,
the Posture Institute,
um,
that's the vaccination of Joseph Meister.
It's not pastor doing the actual
vaccination because as I said,
he wasn't a physician.
And this is the posture institute founded
in 1887 with Louis posture himself.
It's its first director committed to
biomedical research and Paris and to a
series of satellites,
institutes elsewhere in the world.
It followed the public health strategy
of vaccination pioneered by pastor and
now by gender and now consolidated by
pastor the founding of this institute.
You'll notice size unimposing nature
gives us the opportunity to noting note in
passing another aspect of
19th and 20th century science,
the way in which it became a focal point
for competing nationalisms and a way
familiar to us from the
Cold War competition between
the US and the u s a star.
In any case,
there is a clear case in the 19th century
with the rivalry between Louie pastor
and Robert call the embodiments and icons
of French and German medical science
of to hostile national powers.
The Pasta in institute in Paris rivaled
the caulk institute in Berlin and that
brings us, uh, we'll also note
the crypt where a pastor, uh,
is buried. There's a kind of, um,
what should I say,
a worship of posture almost
and of French medical science.
But let's move on to Robert Caulk
who lived from 1843 to 1910.
The second great figure in
the establishment of the
germ theory of disease.
The German scientist who was
20 years younger than pastor.
Now if pastors hallmark
was the imaginative Breck
to his scientific vision,
caulks distinctive feature,
which is scientific rigor,
is more rigorous
techniques of microbiology.
He had to critique a famous critique
of the whole swan flask experiment.
He argued that pastor had been lucky
because Penn town in the nation was
possible.
He developed the plate technique using
the petri dish and solid culture and he
developed staining
techniques for microscopy.
Would I'd particularly like
you to note is his methodology,
which he embodied in,
uh,
what are called Koch's postulates.
This was the methodology for determining
that a suspected microbe is the
causative agent of a particular disease.
He said,
you could know this under four conditions.
First,
the organism suspected as a pathogen must
be found in all animals suffering from
the disease.
In other words,
it has to be universally present where
the disease is present and then the
organism must be isolated from a
diseased animal and grown in culture.
Third,
the cultured organism must cause the
disease when introduced into a healthy
animal.
And lastly,
the organism must be re isolated from
the experimentally infected animal.
Now these postulates are some of the most
famous in medical science and more the
model for establishing germs as
pathogens for other diseases,
no calls.
Microscopy had a number
of immediate implications.
His staining raised the idea
that if you could stain,
you could also have an
idea of magic bullets,
what later became antibiotics,
but core didn't pursue
that particular interest.
The other was this led
to reliable differential
diagnosis and therefore a more
properly based node Zala gene.
It could lead also to major public
health measures and ultimately to
developments in therapeutics.
It furthered the sanitary idea and
gave it a firm scientific basis and in
irrefutably proved the
raw truth of contagion,
aneurysm rather than anti
contagion aneurysm as patent
coffer learn to its cost,
but immediately there wasn't. It didn't
employ and I think we should not this,
the understanding of disease
did not immediately lead.
There's therapeutic advances.
Remember what happened in Naples during
the cholera of 1894 caulks idea was used
for a very negative therapeutic
method that is acid animus that were
administered to patients well call also
moved forward on other diseases applying
the methods he had developed that pastor
had developed in the 1870s and applying
his own rigorous postulates in
1882 the most famous of all,
he isolated the bacterium
that causes tuberculosis.
The most,
um,
prevalent disease of the time.
The paper that cork presented in 1882 was
one of the most dramatic and important
moments in the history of medicine.
Tuberculosis was not feared
in the same way color was,
but it was unquestionably the
greatest killer of the 19th century.
And until 1882 it was shrouded in mystery.
Suddenly call cast a new shaft of life
revealing to the world that he and Rau
unraveled the entire
mystery of a TD ology.
Then in 1883 he followed up this discovery
with another that was almost equally
influential.
In 1883 he isolated the
vibrio cholerae call,
then had discovered and
demonstrated the role of pathogens,
the ones responsible for two of the
most prevalent and feared 19th century
diseases. This marked, as I said,
the definitive triumph of contagion.
Assam and the 1880s and nineties were
a golden age of microbiology with the
pathogens for being discomfort for
a whole range of other diseases.
This was an extraordinary
period and medical science.
The pathogens were discovered
for gonorrhea, bubonic plague,
dysentery, tetanus, the common
bacteria have wound infections,
staph infections and others.
The power of docs.
Of course there were still few benefits
for patients until the turn of the new
century.
The quip was made that
the main beneficiaries at
first of the germ theory of
disease work physicians
rather than patients,
but there was a major exception and
that was not in medicine but in surgery.
And this introduces the third major
figure of our trio establishing the germ
theory of disease.
And that's Joseph Lister,
who lived from 1827 to 1912 and made
his major contributions in Scotland.
He was professor of surgery at Edinboro
University where he was appalled by the
numbers of patients who died after
otherwise successful operations.
You know the old joke about the
operation being successful, just too bad,
the patient died well,
postures idea immediately struck him for
it's lifesaving practical implications.
That is he made practical use of postures,
discovery about the role of airborne
germs and causing wound infections in
surgery.
Now,
surgery before lister had
a number of major limits.
There was pain itself
and the need for speed.
There was blood loss and
there was septicemia.
The result was that the major body
cavities remained off limits the abdominal
cavity, the thoracic
cavity, the cranial cavity,
and there was a high rate
of death from infection.
The idea was thought by physicians at
the time that the infection was arose
through spontaneous
generation as tissue dot died,
they gave off toxins that caused infection
and saw infection was simply accepted
as inevitable.
Normal part of surgery.
Lister's surgical revolution occurred
with the work he published on the
antiseptic principle and the practice
of surgery in 1864 the implications of
postures work on fermentation without,
you could have an analogy.
If posture was right,
there was no spontaneous generation and
airborne micro organism penetrated the
wound and caused infection or septicemia.
The remedy was to prevent the
penetration of the microorganism,
the idea of antisepsis.
So lister accepted postures,
insight that infections,
we're not a chemical reaction caused
by oxidation when air touched a wound.
Instead infection was the
result of contamination from
the outside of the wound
by microorganisms is solution.
We'll first was this the carbolic
spray device that he invented.
What you did was to spray
the air around the patient,
applying carbolic acid
also directly to the wound,
and lister also washed his hands before
operating and sterilized is interests.
Instruments. There's a stylized, uh,
idea of a lister type
surgical technique at work.
We'll, until listers, revolutionary
innovation surgery had been an emergency,
a treatment of last resort because of the
wound infection after 1866 it became a
normal procedure.
There were other innovations
as well that went with it.
His contemporaries improved on lister,
you'll see that here.
They aren't wearing masks
for example or gowns.
Those were introduced and gloves made
from vulcanized rubber were introduced in
the 1890s but really became a part of
best practice only from about the time of
the first world war.
This also revolutionized obstetrics
with the conquest of poor pro fever with
hospital and clinical procedures.
Then we're transformed
by the antiseptic idea.
So by the 1890s,
you have the consolidation of the
germ theory of disease revolutionizing
medicine and becoming accepted throughout
the international medical profession.
I'd like to mention a,
the impact also on culture
and this particular book,
um,
which is by Bram Stoker,
which is Dracula published
in 1897 that gives us,
I would argue,
expression and it really dramatic and
I just read it again and really scary.
I sure you, uh, uh,
idea of anxieties about infection.
Okay.
No.
Dracula is really for its
time a high tech novel and it,
you see all about the latest scientific
and medical inventions and ideas.
It contains the phonograph,
the telephone, stenography,
railroads,
the two wheeled bicycle and in medicine
it deals with the latest inventions in
psychiatry and blood transfusion,
infectious diseases.
And indeed I would argue it also involves
what was the cutting edge scientific
idea in Madison at the time,
the possibility of vector borne diseases
like malaria and full area it pre then
it's just at the time when we're
going to see tropical medicine.
We'll look at next time becomes the
cutting edge of late 19th century,
early 20th century medical science.
Now you know the drill about Dracula,
how Count Dracula,
the Word Dracula comes from
the Romanian word draw cool,
which means a devil, a little devil. Um,
and you know how he lived the count in a,
the evil count in Transylvania,
in Romania,
in the Carpathian mountains.
And the point and point is he is
traveling by ship from the Black Sea port
aboard a Russian vehicle through the
Mediterranean and up along the coast of
Spain and France work you lands by
ship and Britain at the port of Whitby.
Then he travels by train and
is transported by railroad
from Whitby to London.
Where his plan is to ravage
the huge population of London.
Now what does that remind you of?
Doesn't that reminds me?
I'm going to argue that Dracula
is many things in the literature.
You'll see that Dracula is a metaphor
and this has often said for repressed
sexuality in the Victorian era,
you'll find interpretations of it as
expressing also a repressed homoeroticism.
Okay?
In it we also find expression
of the battle of good and evil.
No, that's our friend, uh, Dracula.
And you'll see love never dies.
The idea of this actual idea is clearly
some 200 films have been made of Dracula
and you can see clearly a possible
sexual ideas in films such as this and
they're clearly also here.
But what I want to argue,
it's what's been neglected so often,
and I think it's really important as
I want to argue the Dracula is also an
allegory of infectious disease,
not a specific disease,
but diseases like plague and cholera
that originated in eastern Europe and
traveled just as Dracula did by ship
and by railroad that they had count
Dracula's goal of ravaging
industrial cities,
huge population centers like London.
And it's interesting that the vampire
hunters in the novel are doctors,
physicians whose mission is to
destroy the invading the empire.
Also involved,
we see is the seasonality.
It's not by chance that Count
Dracula arrives in late August,
September, justice cholera
would have, or bubonic plague.
And we see miasma autism in the
novel, the flowers, the garlic,
the mis surrounding Dracula.
And I would argue that Dracula as
a composite of many infections,
here's the handsome count again,
and I'd like to show you one
more handsome picture of him. Um,
and that's not one.
Uh,
and I would argue that this clearly
makes me think also of a vector borne
disease and possibly is this a million
miles removed from malaria and film area,
which we'll be talking about
next week. So I urge you, uh,
also to read Dracula.
I'm sure you'll enjoy it as much as I did.